♪♪
[ Waves crashing ]
[ Bells tolling ]
♪♪
[ Breathing heavily ]
Whoa!
It's a mirror-face guy!
I am your confessor.
Sorry, pal.
I don't do confessions.
But I know this dweeb
named Mike.
He'd totally be into it.
I am here
for only you.
Ooh, sexy.
Why don't you show me
what's underneath that robe,
honeybunch.
Silence!
[ Bells toll ]
Mueller...
[ Tolling continues ]
Can't get me, copper.
I mean, Mueller.
I mean...copper.
Are you so morally vacant
that you cannot confess
to your crimes,
even within
your own mind?
Yes. No?
Uh...
Where's the mirror guy?
He was fun.
I brought a cheeseburger
for the confessor,
but I guess you're not him.
Wait! No!
No, no, no.
I'm the confessor.
Yeah, yeah.
I could do that.
I did it all --
conspiracy, obstruction,
collusion,
conjunction junction,
what's my function?
[ Sternly ]
I want the truth.
I can't handle
the truth.
Are you not alone,
drifting in a sea
of self deception.
I already know about
the money laundering
and the data mining
and those dirty deeds
in your Russian hotel room.
Ooh, yeah!
Still got it.
You'll never be free,
unless your confession
is absolute.
Okay.
I made Eric ugly
on purpose.
And you are a-a-a liar,
are you not?
Yeah, it's true.
Half the crowd
at my inauguration
were blow-up dolls.
Yes! Now the truth
is flowing like an icy...
I'm jealous of coal miners
'cause they can get away
with doing black-face.
Childish!
Ooh, little Donny's afraid!
Poor little Donny.
More.
I don't even like having
sex with women.
I just want people
to think I do.
[ Groaning ]
Donny made naughty on
Mommy's favorite dollies
before she came home.
I moved on those dollies
like a bitch.
You're a bad, bad
little boy.
Mommy was always
in charge.
But being bad
made me in charge.
Little Donny diaper boy.
Give me more.
Uh, I can't read.
I once ate dog poop.
I'm getting dementia like
my mom and dad and mom.
More! More!
I paid for sex!
Well, not with everyone.
Some people, incredibly,
actually like you.
But I tried to pay them.
And then I paid them not
to talk about it
because nobody likes me!
Nobody wants me!
Your closest confidants have
all abandoned you.
I've absorbed them
in the infinite reach
of my unending
investigation.
[ Bells toll ]
Flynn.
Gates.
Nunberg.
Papadopoulos.
Nunay Poperpuss.
Ivanka.
No.
They are all
a part of me now!
Ivanka: [ Echoing ]
Daddy? Daddy?
Baby?
Now you will join them
in the everlasting
purgatory
of the justice system.
No!
I'll never join you!
Bye-bye, Donny.
For now.
♪♪